in this video not only are we going to
pay attention to how these two molecules
will react but we'll also pay attention
to the stereochemistry of the end
product to do that we have to pay
attention to the stereochemistry of the
things that we're beginning with and
this is just regular hydroxide anion
we've seen this show before this is
going to act as the nucleophile it's not
the strongest nucleophile it's not
iodide but it's a pretty good
nucleophile so we have a good
nucleophile here good good nucleophile
we have a good nucleophile and then over
here we have a carbon it's not a it's
not a methyl carbon it's not binding to
a bunch of hydrogen's that would be a
super fast sn2 reaction this guy could
attack it and it's not even a primary
it's a secondary but we said well if we
have a pretty good nucleophile this
guy's going to want to give his
electrons enough to that that this will
happen it won't be the fastest reaction
but we can get an sn2 reaction
especially if the solvent is the right
type of solvent and we'll talk more
about this in future videos on what type
of solvents are good for sn2 reactions
versus sn1 so we're going to have an sn1
reaction we're going to have this
situation we're going to have the
situation where one of the electrons
from the nucleophile will be given to
this to this secondary carbon it's
bonded to two other carbons so it'll be
given to the secondary carbon and then
that will allow this bromine to swipe
the carbon that it was bonded with and
we know bromine is pretty
electronegative so it's going to do that
it's going to swipe that electron and
then at the end at the end you're going
to end up with a you're going to end up
with a bromine or I should say bromide
now that it's an anion a bromide anion
it swiped that electron before bromine
had one two three four five six seven
valence electrons now it's going to
swipe this one over here so now it'll
have eight one two three four five six
seven eight put a negative charge it
just gained an electron and then what
the other stuff will look like this so
that carbon let me draw that carbon in
the center that's just like this and
notice bromine is leaving
from the right and the hydroxide is
attacking or it's or it's giving its
electron from the lefferts bonding from
the left so what's it going to look like
well we have this I guess we could call
this ethyl group coming straight out
forward we have this ethyl group coming
straight out forward we have this ethyl
group coming straight out forward still
ch2 ch3 we have the hydrogen that is
still going to be behind the carbon so
that hydrogen is still behind the carbon
so I could draw it like I could draw it
like this the bromine is no longer there
you still have this methyl group above
it so that is ch3 and now this hydroxide
has has attacked right and the same I
guess direction that the bromine is
leaving in but from the opposite side so
that's leaving front to the right this
guy's entering from the left so then the
hydroxide will be bonded like this will
be bonded like this o H now we just
described a classic sn2 reaction this is
a classic sn2 and I always like to
emphasize the sn2 because my brain
always confuses it with sn1 so I'd like
to remind myself this is sn2 because it
is substitution with substitution with a
nucleophile that's the hydroxide in this
case and the number two says the rate
determining step and there is only one
step in this reaction involves both of
the reactants and this definitely is
involving both of the reactants so this
is a classic sn2 well the point of this
video is to see what happened to the
stereochemistry of this molecule
obviously the different molecule on this
side but did it switch from left to
right or I guess we should say from did
it switch from R to s or s to R to say
it stay in the same direction so let's
name this one using our naming
mechanisms I'm going to call it the RS
naming scheme and and and then we'll
name this one and then we'll see if we
switched if we switched our handedness
so first of all let's just name the base
molecule and this is good review so
what's our longest carbon chain we have
one two three four carbons and actually
I probably shouldn't have named it that
way because this broom
group is closer to that end so I should
not I should number it starting from
here we have one two three four carbons
so methyl is one carbon ethyl is two
carbons propyl is three carbons or probe
is three so its beaut beaut is four
carbons so it's going to be Butte and
it's all single bond so it's going to be
a butane butane and on the number two
carbon we have a bromo group so it's
2-bromobutane to bromo to bromo butane
and this is a chiral carbon so we have
to describe its handedness and we know
it's a chiral carbon because everything
it's bonded to is different this is it's
bonded to two carbons but this is a
whole ethyl group there's two carbons
here there's only one over there and
obviously it's a hydrogen and that's a
bromine so what's its handedness and to
do that you want to put the the group
that has the lowest atomic number in the
back and we know hydrogen has the lowest
atomic number so it's already in the
back so that's convenient we don't have
to do any visualization of how do you
rotate it so you put it in the back so
that's already in the back and then you
just you just count from you just start
so also what we have in the front is
this guy this guy this guy and what you
do is you start with the guy with the
highest atomic number and that would be
bromine right there and then you go in
the direction you go in a circle in the
direction of the next highest atomic
number carbon and carbon is the tie the
tiebreakers that this carbon is bonded
to another carbon while this carbon is
only bonded to hydrogen's so you're
gonna go in this direction right here
you're going to go clockwise you're
going to go let me do that in another
color you are going to go clockwise and
so and the way I like to think about is
on top we're going to are going to we're
going to the right we're going clockwise
so this is our that you s is to the left
for sinister R for the right that's the
way I think of it so it's R so this is
our two bromo butane so its handedness
is R now what's this thing over here
what's this thing over here well first
of all once again we have four carbons
we have
we have 1 1 2 3 4 carbons so Butte will
be our prefix but since the group that
we are attached to is an OHA Pitts a
hydroxide group
this is actually an alcohol so this is a
little bit of practice of naming
alcohols so we still have Butte as our
prefix we still have Butte as our prefix
but we wouldn't call it butane since it
has an OHA air we'll call it butanol
beYOU butanol and maybe I'll write that
in blue to show that the annul the annul
comes from comes from the Oh H view
butanol or maybe we could say the all
comes from maybe that's even better let
me just write butanol view and all yeah
that's a different color Butte view ton
and then all comes the fact that we have
the O H there we're dealing with an
alcohol and it's attached to the number
2 carbons so we'll call it 2 butanol 2
butanol so we went from having to bromo
butane to 2 butanol but what is the
handedness of this so same exercise you
put the lowest atomic number in the back
that's the hydrogen it's already in the
back and then you start with the atom or
the group that has a highest atomic
number or of the things that are bonded
to this chiral carbon is still chiral
all of these things are different
you start with whatever has the highest
atomic number this oxygen has the
highest atomic number and you go in the
direction of the next highest this
carbon and that carbon are tied but this
one is also attached to other carbons
while this is attached only to
hydrogen's so we go in this direction we
go in that direction or counterclockwise
or in the Sinister direction of the
leftward direction so this is s s for
sinister s 2 butanol so the whole point
of this video is to show you that when
you have an sn2 reaction with a chiral
aunt wake i guess you could say on a
chiral carbon that it changes the carbon
stereochemistry it changes its its
handedness it went from i guess you can
view it as being right-handed to
left-handed
the way it's it's it's well for lack of
a better word it changes its chirality
you could have to even imagine actually
a situation where a bromine comes in
attacks and this bromine leaves it and
then you would actually have the same to
bromo butane but it would actually
switch its handedness and I want this is
super important because this matters if
you care whether or not you want to you
want to change you want to flip the
stereochemistry or not what we're going
to see in the next video is or maybe
maybe the video after that is that in
sn1 reactions that you don't not only do
not flip your stereochemistry that you
kind of lose you know if all of your
molecules were one handedness your by
prot your end product is going to be a
mix of the two handedness when you do an
sn1 reaction but sn2 you flip the
handedness you saw here we started with
our 2-bromobutane the sn2 reaction
happened we ended up with s and it makes
complete sense you view this you know
this is coming from the backseat view
this is kind of an umbrella right this
was this was kind of an upturned
umbrella this was the handle and when
this comes and he becomes a handle and
the umbrella flips in that direction so
that's one way to think about it so
visually it also should make a little
bit of sense